Hi everyone and welcome back to
another VC libraries Open code
review in today's special
Intercontinental Edition, we
will be reviewing site brands PR
to implement P25O5R5 monadic
functions for state expected.
This is a C + + 23 feature. So
here is the PR 3361. I've got
the tracking issue open that as
usual lists the feature test
macro change where the value is
increasing. So we'll be looking
out for that.
The actual paper which is adding
a functions and then or else
transform and transform error.
These are being added to stood
expected and they're somewhat
similar to the other monadic
functions that were added to
optional that we previously
reviewed, and I've opened up the
corresponding section of the
working paper here. So let's
dive right into the code.
OK alt Click to minimize
everything.
Umm, OK. So we're adding a new
test, we've got changes to libx
skips, changes to our century to
header arrival, core H846 lines
of product code change the new
test and the feature test macro
as usual. I like to eat dessert
first, so I will review the
small changes first. So I've
also core we are listing the new
paper.
In the C + 23 guarded section.
Yeah, that's correct and it is
in sorted order that looks good.
Let's make sure there are no
typos.
Yeah, Alex, good. We've got the
increased feature test macro.
Because expected is a. See was
supposed 23 feature to begin
with.
So essentially, there's no.
Uh, there's no variation in the
macro. We have a special section
below. If we have something like
a C + + 20 feature that changes
in 23. But in this case the
feature will appear fully formed
in C23 with these monadic
functions. So we just have the
new value, which is quite easy.
I'm pretty sure this is right.
Well, let's make sure there's
some typos. Yeah, perfect.
Ensure I copy pasted it from
your comments.
So that's good for the.
Yes, yeah. And we could, we
could double check the working
draft as well. In this case. I'm
not too concerned that I got the
the value wrong because it's set
to the value that was the
current month when the changes
were voted into the working
paper. Every once in a while
they do something weird with the
feature test macros. It's good
to occasionally double check I,
Katie.
Yeah, this is lexical analysis,
cat.
But yeah.
I always double check for typos
because it's so easy to like.
Accidentally copy paste like one
line off if somebody copy paste
from the working paper.
Every once in a while patches
something fun. So let's look at
the feature test macro test. So
this is the CPP Lib expected.
Again we've got the new value
update and all three locations.
Perfect.
So nice and easy. I've got the
new test being added.
Umm, as the right value here,
I'm just eyeballing it. Yep, and
it's being added in sorted
order. Minac functions for state
expected. OK, correct test
directory name that that one
gets occasionally type out and
it won't be caught by our test
harness because test dot list is
used only by the internal test
harness, which someday we will
fix. Hopefully we just need to
unify our test harnesses. So
here's the new ENV list. So this
feature depends on concepts and
is otherwise a C + 23 features.
So concepts, latest matrix, but
it tolerates.
The permissive mode, so there's
no struct here, so that's good.
And then, oh, got a double
check. We've got our banner. So
that's right. The new test,
which I'll come back to, but we
do have the banner. OK, I'll
quickly scan to see if there's
any unnecessary use of stood.
No. Excellent.
Just in the title. OK, so I
think we're already ohh the also
the libs X skips.
So because we and Lipsius Plus
implement features at different
paces, we've got.
A version macro test there that
will fail because we've
increased the version test macro
here or the feature test macro
so the skip comment is list CPP
has not implemented P25O5R5
monadic functions for STD
expected exactly down a call.
This is being added in our known
issues area.
Yeah, this is near the top. This
is a issues known to. I could
keep expanding. I guess one more
time.
Yeah, issues known upstream that
they'll realize that they need
to update this macro.
So in the expected results, we
use forward Slash Pass beginning
with stood and we need to have
fail or skipped at the end. So
this is all correct and then in
the internal skip test text
again this one is if this is
messed up we won't find it till
we mirror the PR. Internally
this is the fun part of working
in a open source. Still internal
code base. We don't have a stood
component, everything is
backslashes and no fail. That's
exactly identical. So that's
good. Aside from those
differences.
Avoiding divergence between
these files makes them
maintainable again, something we
should resolve someday. OK,
let's actually look at the
product code.
That's up to the top.
OK, we've also got updates to
the situations here. I'll double
check these quickly. Let's see.
Can I split? Maybe I wanna
monitor. That's like wider than
what I have here.
Aspect ratio. It's not the most
convenient.
Of course, we could always, you
know, change the STL to be like
80 columns, but the cure would
be worse.
120 columns is in general so
much nicer to a read. OK, so I
always double check this because
it's easy to get these citations
or I'm 4928 is the right paper
number. That's all curing
properly, but it looks like the
place where these requirements
have are specified is actually
changed every once in a while.
Stable names change or sometimes
stuff gets moved around between
sections, so there's now
something expected under
general. Let's see if search
will cooperate.
Yes. So this is the unexpected.
And Scroll down paragraph two.
OK, indeed paragraph two. I'm
talks about the requirements, so
they're all coming from 2.
They're all the same here, so
that's good. We've also got a
stable name citation here.
This one doesn't appear with the
working paper because we're not
citing any specific paragraph.
This is indeed the constructor
section. We've got some cleanup
comments, I guess I can.
Change this now that I saw
talked about in the the history
of the PR. No, I don't wanna go
up to the top of the working
paper.
Where we're changing strength
and to be attached directly here
against no except saying, hey,
we're doing something a bit
stronger than what the standard
specifies, so fairly minor
cleanup. It's OK to mix that in
with the features.
OK, so now we've got some
support machinery.
And this is to enforce.
The requirements for expected
because we're going to need to
refer to them elsewhere.
Previously, we did that directly
within expected itself. So we
had export template class
expected and then we immediately
began static asserting stuff
about it. But now we're going to
extract this so we can use it
elsewhere. So we also have A
tag. So this is an internal tag.
Oh, and by the way, with export
stood that is for the new C + 23
feature modules.
I'm not expecting any modules
impact for this feature because
all of these things are being
added or member functions, not
top level functions or classes,
so expected will still of course
be marked as export and these
will all be just attached to
that. All the internal stuff
does not get exported. That's
the cool thing about modules. So
nothing to worry about there.
We've got A tag following our
user usual convention. It has an
explicit and defaulted
constructor to make it hard to
accidentally construct. This is
called ugly.
Under score construct expected
from invoke result tag. That's
nice and self-explanatory. Then
we have a concept. Any use of
concepts needs to be guarded by
SQLite concepts. I believe the
whole feature is.
Yeah, the the entire file is
guarded by that.
OK, excellent. I can also open
it up here in case I need
context. Yeah, so.
Umm. If anybody tries to include
this, we emit a nice warning
saying the contents of expected
to available only with 23 or
later, and in particular we need
concepts.
OK. Thanks Sai.
So I lost my place.
Here we go. I think I can go
ahead and maximize this now.
OK, so this is now is invoke
constructable.
So we're going to ask, can we
construct?
A transformed invoke result tee.
From stuff.
Now it's interesting that this
is using parenthesis syntax
which is.
Famously willing to do a C style
semantic casts, UM instead of is
constructible. I know we talked
about this a bit in the the
comments that it relates to or
potentially relates to.
You deferred temporary
materialization. Would it be
Yeah.
possible to express this as an
is constructible, or must it be?
I think it has to be this way
because the so the idea behind
This sort of syntax here.
this is that you might want to
support types in transform or
transform error which are non
movable. So if you're if you
pass for example a Lambda which
returns non movable type by
value then due to deferred
temporary materialization that
can be constructed in place
directly into the.
The expected object and doing.
Umm.
Doing is constructible on invoke
result doesn't take into account
the deferred temporary
materialization so that it says
no. You can't do this even
though you can.
Interesting. Nicole, you have
your hand up.
Uh, so it's not a particularly
an issue because we're casting
from.
Team to remove CV raft but that
is technically a sea cast of, so
if we want to make sure that
we're not using a ccast, we
could use static cast instead.
Uh, it's good point.
But also like.
It it's not a sea castle. Ever
be anything other than a static
cast?
I I would definitely prefer a
static cast if it has the same
So.
semantics I'm looking for. Is
constructible to remind myself
how it works. Where do we put
it?
It's not a a other.
It's not a unary type tray.
This convertible or is it type
property queries? Nope.
Type properties.
There we go.
OK, so the definition of is
constructible.
Specified to see below.
I used to know how this works
before she has 17 changed
everything. It is constructible.
Here we go.
The predicate condition shall be
satisfied if and only if the
following variable definition
will be well formed. They are
never interpreted as a function
declaration. Make a tea.
Named variable out of Declval
args.
This.
Does handle deferred temporary
materialization?
The Declval adds ref ref doesn't
it?
It.
All the declval.
Because we are, I see.
So it acts as if you it acts as
if you like returned.
And our value reference, so the
different.
The args are of.
Yeah.
Ah, OK. And if the if the Lambda
itself, I guess the.
They're the result of invoking.
So you're saying if this thing
Yeah. So if the result of
invoking.
is not movable.
Is non movable, then it gets
still can be constructed in
place and the UM the paper. The
paper was written with that in
If it's the exact same type.
mind, such that it's specified
that we have to support that so.
OK. A question before I actually
get to that. Do we have test
coverage for this?
Yes.
Excellent. OK. So then this is a
reasonable, but I do like the
idea of using a static cast
here, which should be exactly
equivalent in semantics, because
we never want to Conn's cast or
a reinterpret cast, which are
the other things that the C, the
functional functional style C
semantics syntax is going to do.
So out here, Cole.
Suggests.
Using static cast here as.
Ah type args.
Is a.
Technically, a functional style
C semantics cast, which we
prefer to avoid, we we
absolutely avoid all the season
tax cases except for void. We
try to avoid the functional
style casts as much as possible,
although there are some cases
where it's necessary.
Umm with like user client types
and there's some ranges scenario
which I always forget which
really can't use like braces.
Although in theory and some of
those cases probably could use
static cast, we just haven't
done that everywhere. OK, so I
Nicole suggest using static cast
here as type bars as technically
a functional style C semantics
cast which we prefer to avoid.
OK, so let's actually look at
the machinery template, class
owner, fun class owner ties
concept is invoke constructable.
We're requires fun. Refer funk.
Vowels. So can we make?
The invoke result T.
Of invoking fun on ties. This is
all correct, because when we're
taking ref ref. If we just pass
the type itself, that preserves
the value category properly and
is not redundant like saying fun
refresh would be identical but.
Unnecessary. So we don't do
that. Then we want to remove the
CV ref from that.
That cosmetic.
It essentially is cause you
should in theory be able to
construct a const whatever, even
a constant out other stuff.
But this is certainly a very
cheap and it's simpler to think
about. OK, I like that then
stood in.
It certainly needs to be a
removed reference T.
Not yes. Yeah, yeah. Because,
yeah, trying to construct a
reference out of it would not do
what we want.
Construct from student votes did
forward fun Funk stood 4 ties,
valves OK avoiding ADL. That's
great. That's great.
Uh, here are the extracted
requirements. Now template class
tie. This is following the same
check unexpected argument
machinery.
Which? Uh, if I can open this
up, here we go. Check. I need
not case.
Yeah. This thing we had a.
And still have a helper struct
that always drives from true
type that goes and enforces a
bunch of static asserts.
We don't actually have a lot of
precedent of this in the code
base, so it's nice that it
occurs right near to the next
one. We need to add because
usually we just need to enforce
like one or two static
assertions, but for unexpected
we had like 5 different things
we needed to check, so wrapping
them up in a helper struct was
convenient and so we're doing
the similar thing here. Check
expected argument. Also dry some
true type.
Umm.
Oh, this is not being
specialized. This is simply the
primary template itself. Why do
we need to specialize?
Uh, no, that unexpected argument
behaves the same way. I was
getting confused by the four
declaration of unexpected here.
OK, so it's always primary
template, which is the
standard's term 4 template that
has not yet been specialized.
Template costs high start check
expected argument, derive some
true type, stacked a bunch of
stuff. These are all they should
be exactly be the same as
before, not a reference, not a
function. The citations are
being updated. This is the same
paragraph.
OK, here we're not changing the
stable name or anything. Yeah,
it's just updating the working
paper. I guess I can check to
make sure that the paragraph
number has not changed. I am
very picky.
Umm, because if we, if we ever
let the paragraph numbers get
out of sync, we'll never be able
to find her. It'll be hard to
find what we were trying to
cite.
Type 2 or paragraph two or type
is a valid value type. If cool
things are satisfied.
And then the CP-17 destructible
things are different. Yeah,
paragraph 2's good.
OK.
So they're all sitting paragraph
2.
So it's not a reference, not a
function, and then the diff is
not really convenient here.
There's this array coming from.
Is that new?
Now looks new here.
I don't believe I added that.
Intentionally at least so.
There's.
Is the is the diff or was this
copy pasted from unexpected
possibly?
Unexpected forbids array. It
looks like there might be copy
paste or I don't know if it's
wrong yet I got to look at the
standard.
But OK, so now now since I've
seen something unusual, I'm
getting paranoid. I I need to
double check everything.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
So we got the not a reference.
We got not a function and the
the wording I guess is is also
the same, not a reference, not a
function. So then it's the not
an array that's appearing out of
thin air.
Umm, we'll come back to that
then here the diff is making
things nice in place T and
expect tea and can't be
unexpected itself. So those are
all. Those are all fine. But
what's going on with the array?
So let's look at the standard.
Umm, a type T is a valid value
type for expected if remove CBT
is void.
Or a complete non array object
type that is not in place T and
expect or specialization of
unexpected.
Interesting.
So we're enforcing teens to be a
complete nonary object type
where we just missing this
before that's interesting.
Yes, we were.
OK, so this is uh, this is
correcting a deficiency.
Yeah, I I noticed that's when I
was comparing the conditions and
Because the.
Yeah.
added the not array case.
Yeah, we still check error. OK,
interesting. Next, Casey.
So let's actually, for my own
education, make sure that this
is actually now exhaustive. So.
We allow it to be void.
Which is not a reference of
function array, so it won't
trigger any of that.
Umm, we can't check
completeness, of course says we
non array. That's the array part
object types. Here I've immersed
the standard definition. Object
types are non void, non
reference non function. So we
can't be referenced. We can't be
function. But we do permit void
so that's good. And then we
specifically forbid in place T
and expect T or specialization
of unexpected. OK, so this is.
Uh, complete and correcting a
deficiency. Thank you.
It's good. I wonder if that was
added at some point. I could
have sworn that when we
originally reviewed expected, we
made sure it was exhaustive, so
either we missed something or
they passed it later and we
missed it, which is unusual. We
could do archaeology to find out
exactly what happened, but I'm
not too interested at this
point. I'm just happy to get the
fix. OK, so we got the struct
there. We're retaining the
export, stood on class, expected
the Div is just confused here.
And then we static assert that
ties satisfies the expected
argument and then error
satisfies unexpected, so that's
good. We've got a stable name
change, which is fairly unusual.
That's not helping.
Umm I've got 2 copies that work
in draft open.
There we go. Expect object cons
for constructor.
Yeah, there it is.
They're stable asterisk.
Uh, clean up to attach,
strengthen there, clean up plus
clang format. OK, not too
concerning.
Some paragraph changes since I
haven't seen any issues with
paragraphs, I'm less concerned
about these now.
16 is value or?
Yep. Value or.
18 is the referee version of
value or?
Yep.
That's the mandates.
OK.
Ah, some questions from Nicole
talking to Sai about.
The specification value or.
This is very warm, no error or.
Yes. So the context here is the.
Possible API symmetry?
Umm, the template argument to
error or is defaulted to error
so that you can call it with an
empty brace list, whereas the.
Uh and template argument to
value or is not defaulted, so
you cannot pass anti braces to
value or cynical comment was.
Do we need to make an issue and?
My answer was maybe, maybe not.
I don't know. I I looked at the.
Alright.
I looked at the original minutes
from the.
AWG calls and.
And it seemed like.
It was to support this kind of
refactoring.
Where you have like an an error
code and you're doing like
calling a a function to to test
for an error and and you wanna
Umm.
make this this kind of refactor
to to get back a default error
afterwards.
So that was their reason for
having the default on the the
error or my.
Kind of guessed from from
reading the notes was that they
find a A.
A good use case for this for
error or and.
Umm.
I didn't find necessarily strong
one for for adding this to value
or but I don't know if it's
worth filing an issue on 1st for
symmetry sake.
Umm, it seems like it might be
worth sending a mail to library
evolution because this is really
a design question. It looks like
Yeah.
it's not just an outright the
misspecified the API or they
just forgot something during an
edit, or maybe not a full
library evolution issue, but
just a mail to the reflector
asking hey was did anybody think
about this?
Umm, because it's always
possible that they patched error
or and then nobody noticed that
value org didn't get patched. Or
Well, it error is error is new
in this paper.
maybe it was intentional.
Ohh OK, that's the 10. But value
or was the existing one.
Value or was already existing
and they added error or as part
Ah.
of this paper, yeah.
OK, so that makes it more likely
that this paper has a cool
innovation that then could have
been possibly, but was not
retroactively applied.
Could be, yeah.
OK, so that it does seem like it
does seem that it merits the
library of evolution.
Issue slash mail.
Say, can you take care of this
or should we file an issue right
now in the repo as a reminder?
And I can, if you just write a
note there, I'll. I'll send an
OK.
e-mail to the reflector and.
I'll follow up and.
And on that common thread.
I still need to figure out how
to get my Microsoft e-mail
working with the reflector.
Let's say paths. Let's say OK,
we should send an e-mail to the
library evolution reflector and
ask whether value or should be
changed.
OK, great.
Umm so dropping the this or
probably moving?
Thanks diff UM ohh. There's like
all the new code.
Is it ever going to?
OK, expected object EQ.
That actually change.
OK, no change here. It's just
the diff gets confused. Template
class under score Utah equals
error. So here I actually do
want to have.
Actually, sorry for jumping back
and forth. Class template
expected there's error or and
then everything else is an
expected object of an attic.
But there are some patching
here.
Oh. Oh, here's where the array
thing comes from.
Typo.
Expected Object General did not
used to forbid arrays. It said
reference function or possibly C
equal in place T wow, that's
getting messed up unexpect or so
forth. And now they've added a
complete non array object type.
So that's where the delta came
from. Excellent.
Umm. Means we didn't just forget
something. OK, so then we add
the observers the error or and
then the whole monadic
subclause. Anything else? I'm
just looking for all the diffs
the paper could have had also
void OK.
Expected void been attic and
then the error or.
And then that's it, OK.
So now I can look at the working
draft.
Excuse me, am I looking at the
right area? OK, expect object
obs.
Error or OK.
She wanted some side by side.
OK, so you tie error.
OK so here is the first of many
member functions.
Split the this.
OK. And it kind of works. Here
we go. So template class Utah
equals error.
That matches where's my
highlight.
Here are template class G which
we're calling utai is error. OK,
that's good. That's our usual
name for stuff.
This is what I'm server.
All of these are.
They're all observers.
I'm trying to.
See which ones need to discard
where is that there wording.
Error or yeah, you only ever
call this if you want the value.
He's like, what's the error? And
if we don't have one, then get a
fall back. OK, but for these,
these are all taking function
Yeah. So you could reasonably do
them as side effects.
objects. They're doing stuff.
Yeah. OK. So we don't expect any
notice cards for the and then or
else transform transform error.
But all of the errors for the
primary template and the void
specialization should be
nodiscard OK.
Umm we we tried to be quite
careful about following our
criteria for notice card to
avoid false positives, making it
the extremely useful warning. In
fact, we just had our compiler
give Cameron Venkus for the
nodiscard that we applied to
remove if or and remove because
he tried to call that without
sending the result to erase
member function and got a
warning saying hey, this is not
how you use remove and remove
if.
And otherwise that would
assembly compiled into the wrong
thing and the compiler.
So error or is notice card great
returns a context per error.
Takes a Utah Ruff Ruff other.
That's what we're calling E this
is Const. Ref. We are
strengthening the noexcept, so
there's a strengthened and aside
from Clang format.
Being weird here and we sort of
just tolerate this as not worth
turning off clang format.
We need two things to be true is
no throw copy constructable V
the error cause we could.
Return that.
And because both of these need
to be true because we don't know
until runtime which one we're
gonna do is no throw convertible
V utai.
Which is.
The other two error.
Which is the return type and
that is an implicit conversion,
so that's right and the order is
correct. Famously constructable
convertible specify things in
the opposite order. Very easy to
get confused. But we're
converting from Utah to error so
that all looks good.
Uh, you've got the construct 1
here. Then we've got static
certs to emit nice messages to
enforce some mandate, and these
are actually the nono throw
mirrors of the strengthening.
There is copy constructible V
error and we cite is copy
constructible. VE must be true
we when we send messages to the
user. We tried to talk about
names that they would understand
rather than our internal names.
That's great. And we cite in
4928 expect object OBS 20.
Yes. And then is convertible V
from Utah, which is G to error
is convertible VG to E must be
true. OK, that's all good.
And then returns.
If has value, so we test our
internal bool rather than
calling the member function as a
micro optimization is just
simpler. Return stood for GE
stood forward Utah other
correct. Otherwise the internal
error.
And again, we have the data
members, so we don't need to
call error prone. OK, this is
all perfect.
OK, so now that we've seen this,
I can move a bit faster because
now I just need to sort of
mentally look at the
differences. This one doing is
move convertible.
But it still wants his
convertible GE. If we have a if
we need to use the fall back.
And then we need to move the
error, the reference portion OK.
So template class you tie error.
Notice carcass expert error,
error or the recursion is no
through move constructible error
and is no throw convertible from
you tie to error still
strengthened. We need the move
constructible move constructible
good, no typos. The citation
paragraphs need to update 2, so
it's 22 and 23 for the returns,
but 22 for both requirements.
OK, that's good.
If his value, 40 other otherwise
stood, move the unexpected
perfect.
OK, that's error.
Expected object lunatic.
That is the new section.
OK, so we've got some
requirements here.
This is occurring in standard
order, which is great. Here's
the constraint, so template
class fun.
Requires is copy constructible V
the error, so that's a
constraint.
Uh, we are correctly not seeing
any nodiscard let me just do a
quick search to get that out of
the way.
It's going to turn up all the
ones in the context too.
Error or error or these are the
void ones presumably? Or did we
wrap around ohh we wrapped
around?
Yeah.
Umm.
Uh, do they ohh do the error
orders for void not return
anything.
Umm, no, the error isn't for
void are marked as no discard.
Oh dear, I did my search. Miss
him then? Uh kiss.
Our, our.
That's the primary.
This. Yeah, this is void. Ohh.
They're nice card. OK, so my
search missed them. OK, great.
So they're both nice card. Thank
you.
OK, so now I can stop worrying
about nodiscard. Let's go up.
OK, an attic and then.
OK, so template class fun.
Got the constraint constexpr
auto and then take fun refresh
funk L ref.
So here I I guess I can comment
on the naming. This is funk.
Which is reasonable. This is
being passed to the invoke
Protocol, so technically this is
a callable object.
Umm, but since we're
consistently using invoke here,
I'm not too worried about saying
you know, renaming like after
callable or anything. When we
implemented invoke itself, I
Yeah.
tried to be unusually careful
about the naming, saying call by
object when we specifically
meant to generalize notion of
something that could be a
pointer to member, because
that's what revoke handle
specially and using function
object in the standardese term
only when it meant things that
are callable with exactly
parentheses. But the rest of the
code is less strict about that,
and rightly so. We don't need
to.
Constantly use the exact
standard terminology everywhere
I also copied the. I copied the
naming scheme from optional for.
and it aligns with.
Umm.
Chris symmetry.
Yeah, and yeah, that that makes
reading this easier. OK, that's
good. This is not strengthened
because we don't. There would be
little value in saying there is
no throw invocable and all that.
Umm so this says using Utai is
and this mirrors paragraph one.
Remove C graft. The invoke
result T of F on what is the
deck of type of value?
It's an odd way that they
phrased this. We say tie Rev. Is
that the?
Ah, there's, uh, there. The
standard specifies it as
decltype value because it's
stacking together the
definitions of the modifiable
reference and const reference
versions of the member function.
So at this point in the
specification, it doesn't know
which one. It's in constant non
const, but we know that value is
going to return T Rex for Const
ref, so we can just say tie ref
and avoid that whole decltype,
which is simpler and better for
throughput, so that's good.
So we've got that.
And basically every time there's
a difference between the
implementation of the standards.
I tried to understand. Are we
doing something clever here? Are
we doing something bad?
Sometimes clever and bad?
Static Serge. OK, so this is the
mandate. Utah has to be a
specialization of expected.
I'm nitpick here. We like spaces
after our commas that occurs
below.
I.
Let's pack.
Should have a space after the
comma.
Cursed below, so I won't comment
on that anymore. Expected TE.
And that is the the parameters
to expected double colon and
then F.
Here we can just sort of talk
about.
F without caring too much that
it's a rough raff.
This message, say FFRF.
The user doesn't really care
about that. If they really care,
they could look at the the
standard here. They just give us
a thing. Yeah, it's an L value
or an R value, but we just want
the type of the thing. We don't
need to talk about. Oh, you
know, is it sensitive to value
category? If the user knows
about that stuff, they're going
to read the standard anyway. So
this is a little bit.
Imprecise, but it's imprecise in
a good way. It avoids
overloading the user with
information it requires the
return type of F to be a
specialization of expected.
Uh sighting and 4920 expected
object fanatic 3 yes, that's
correct. I want to make sure
there's a space in the proper
place. Yes. OK, that's good.
Umm, there's a a gotcha where if
we wrap a multiline string and
we don't have a space here, then
the message won't have a space
and it's very easy to miss
visually. Always look out for
that because I I love finding
that even though it's like
completely in the PIC stack
assert is saying VC.
Type name.
You tied up bacon air type must
be error. OK, the standard
doesn't think it needs to say
type name, but we're actually
implementing code, so we need to
say type name expect at E and
then F requires the error type.
Of the return type of app.
OK, be the return type has to be
a specialization of expected, so
requires the error type of the
return type of F to be, and that
matches up with E here. OK,
good.
Also Monadic 3 OK, that's right.
So you've got the mandates.
Done. OK, affects equivalent 2,
which is the favorite wording
for an implementer because it
just says hey, do this thing.
Don't worry about too much what
it does. Of course we do need to
transform into something that's
actually implementable if has
value test the data member
returns to invoke avoid ADL
stood forward FF so from funk.
And then our value.
And where the L value forms so
we don't need to move or
anything otherwise return.
You tie with a Paran so here if
we could do.
Don't know if we could do
braces, but we definitely want
static or we would like static
cast of unexpected comma
unexpected, so that's error.
OK. Could we use braces here?
And I'll think so because we so
the the Convention is that when
possible in our new code,
although the old code is quite
inconsistent, we tried to use
braces to construct temporaries
cuz it doesn't look like a
function call. It makes code
more readable.
Umm, but there are sometimes
semantic differences between
parentheses and braces. Famously
for like vector.
And branches stuff, so we can't
unconditionally do that sort of
thing. We can if we know the
type here. Utah is the return
value. We have no idea what this
thing is. It might care about
braces. But wait, it's an
expected you time. Must be an
expected. So it is us.
We can use braces here we we
know what we are.
That would be nicer than static
cast.
And that this this occurs
repeatedly. I would like braces
here.
Let's do that.
Or and then overloads. Yeah,
makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, basically anywhere
that really anywhere we say this
thing, I don't know if that
occurs other than and then.
Well, and then is the only one
where we know that the return
Ah.
type is going to be a
specialization of expected.
Ah, OK.
And you're right, it does indeed
occur only for and then OK.
Umm.
Do we not know it for or else?
Since.
Umm.
And maybe we do.
Yes, yeah, yeah, we do.
Umm.
And that also does use.
Parentheses, parentheses as
well, so.
Umm.
Yeah, for overloads of and then
and or else.
OK, I can go look at orelse.
We're coming back.
Here's an orelse ohh I see it's
a in place value.
Yeah.
OK, I'll update this comment.
Umm.
OK, we're freed since we know
that you tie is a specialization
of expected, we can use braces
to construct utie which would
follow our prevention occurs
below also in or else where Utah
is constructed from in place.
That.
OK, so now the construct
version.
Let's see. There was a comment
and this is the the history.
It's not. It doesn't appear
attached here because I think
the code changed about whether
some of this stuff could be
extracted. Unfortunately there
is a C + 23 feature called
deducing this, but a it has a
problem with the core language
itself. There's a certain corner
case that doesn't exactly handle
that. You could use a ccast, I
believe to work around, but
that's horrible. And in any
event, the question is moot
because right now.
Although MSVC MSVC has
implemented the deducing this
feature, it is not yet supported
in modules and the STL now
supports modules. So at this
time we're not using it at all.
There was a question of, I think
it was from CPP learner. Correct
me if I'm wrong.
Where could these be extracted
out to? A helper function or
helper member function and in
this case I think that's not
really feasible because too much
varies here. We need to return
like value or move value
depending on. Here's the move
value depending on where our
value reference or not. And yeah
that could be like a
straightforward like or
something, but that's adding a
lot of complexity because then
it wouldn't be a direct
translation of the standardese.
We need to think about. OK, what
happens if we extract this out
to a helper?
It's a little bit, I mean it's a
little bit repetitive to have
all these implementations here,
but I think that if we try to
extract it out, it would be
harder to follow.
Umm so I'm I'm OK with this.
In an ideal world, we could just
wave a magic wand and and
specify it once be done with it,
but at this point I think that
repeating it is the simplest
approach. I'd rather have
basically more code that more
directly aligns with the
standard, and I have to think
less whenever I see something
that needs a big transformation.
I got to think hard about.
Yeah. We introduced any
divergence that the user could
observe cause almost everything
is observable. If you look
closely enough.
OK, so we're looking at the
constant reversion here.
Umm, still requires copy
constructible V error constexpr
auto and then for the refund
Const ref.
Using Utah still the same. Yeah,
go ahead.
So I think I think, Nicole, you
had a comment at one point that
actually the.
That requires clause needs to be
is copy constructable via of
const error.
Is that right?
So copy constructor will be.
This is for the and then
construct Rep.
Function. It does not affect.
And then for construct.
I mean technically it could
affect it for wrath, but I think
that.
I feel less.
I I don't feel as strongly about
like.
About that difference, but the
issue is below in and then for
construct rough.
Uh, it required the end event
for contract requires is move
Oh, this one.
constructed will be which is not
a thing that will actually like.
That's not a constraint that
makes sense for construct raft.
Like it's just.
You you'd want contract for up
to be part of.
Yeah.
The const graph.
World.
That that's a bug in the
standard.
I have. Have you filed an LWG
issue about that?
Yeah.
I have not yet if you Scroll
down a little bit on the review.
Yeah, here we go.
Yep.
Yep, councillor foff. Yep,
highly bogus.
Umm. OK so so I asked what's the
protocol here? Do we fix the
code to be correct to file a Dr
filed resolution fixing?
I would say having thought about
it for all 10 seconds, this is a
case where the code is or. The
standard is clearly bogus, and
the right thing to do is
obvious. So in this case I think
we should just fix the code and
simultaneously file a defect
report issue saying. Here's how
we fixed it cuz as written, it's
not the biggest thing in the
world. Nobody would really
notice. It requires a specific
type to really care about this
like I guess a move only yeah.
Would be a move only error type
where you call the constant R
value overload, which is already
pretty hard to call. So in
theory we could just implement
what standard does and nobody
would know, so eventually would
go fix it, but it would be
strictly less work for us to go
fix it now and simultaneous
report it and then when they
voted into the standard like
hey, we already confirmed.
So I think we should just change
the code and file the issue.
So I'll I'll record that here.
Yeah, but so.
Be argument that I would have is
whether.
We want to use is copy
constructible, which I think is
totally reasonable like.
Any construct will construct
will bind to a construct draft.
Like you probably wanted to do a
copy.
Umm. Or the other option, I
think if we're going to say.
That the contract rap.
It's gonna get constructed via
the constructor of constructor
if it's distinct from the
construct constructor.
And I think probably we should
also distinguish the rest.
From the contract, so like using
something like is constructor is
convertible V Const tie ref to
Thai is convertible the tie ref
to tie is convertible B
tirecraft to tie is convertible
be cause tirecraft to pie like
that makes sense.
Yes, that will also be horrible
to transcribe for the recording.
All those type traits.
I I think I will ask.
I'm so sorry whoever said the
described it.
You'll be transcribing this one.
Congratulations. I think since
we have our concepts expert
Casey on the call, my
understanding is that in the
concepts world, we try to avoid
being super duper fine grained
about exactly which operations
were going to perform, because
only types that are extremely
unusable care about that.
My understanding of the concepts
design that we have in 20 and 23
is that we try to have fewer and
higher level concepts and try to
avoid accommodating types that
are very, very strange and a
type that cares about and might
be constructed from a modifiable
lvalue or a constant L value is
extremely strange at that point,
you're sort of descending into
auto Porter territory.
Umm. So according to my
understanding and correct me if
I'm wrong.
It is reasonable for both the L
value and constant L value forms
of this to just say we require
is copy constructible, which is
specified to ask what happens if
I construct this from a constant
L value. So essentially adding
Const when we ask about the
constraint and if the type
happens to behave weirdly, well,
that's bad, that the type
shouldn't do that, which would
then argue for the const our
value overload to the member
function to just ask is copy
constructible.
Even though it would be
specified to.
Well, I guess then the question
is then do we split the
specification to say?
Do we just copy from value in
that case or do we just always
say stood move value?
Which is technically
constructing from a const star
value and yet have the
constraint say is copy
constructible.
Umm, what do you think, Casey?
More anybody in general?
I hate to split the
specification.
But it does really seem like the
right thing to do here. I I
agree with you.
So split the specification and
just make it plain plain copy
from value or just not move from
it.
Yeah.
And and use copy constructable
for the const or value case,
yeah.
OK.
So and then becomes the
equivalent to like I just got
I see so.
moved up under contract.
Basically.
Yeah, I think so.
Like if you look at the effect.
Could could we just remove the
contract Rev in that case
because it'll just call the
contract?
It's a it's equivalent to the
contract.
Function I like I I don't
personally think that the cons
RAF RAF.
Actually.
Benefits us very much here. I I
think it's. I think it's like
just having an extra function
for no good reason.
Unlike optional where you want
it to be like crazy and do
But.
interesting things.
It does feel over generic to me,
but it's basically a design
That.
question.
Yeah.
Yeah, that is, that is entering
design territory.
I I guess we should ask Ellie WG
if if they wanna support.
Different behavior for Const
reference for construct.
Even though we definitely
wouldn't do that in the concepts
No.
to sign, there are Gray areas.
In in optional that have been
perpetrated to expected.
Where they try to go above and
beyond support weird corner
cases that they probably should.
Yeah. The interesting thing,
there are some cases where you
absolutely do want to respect
contract ref like tuple get is a
famous one where I think I found
the LWG issue to say we should
actually support all four
combinations of lvalue, rvalue,
modifiable const, because that
way if you try to.
I do like a stood get on Const R
value tuple and then pass it to
something that wants to reject
temporaries that we properly
handle those. It's unclear to me
whether that applies to this end
then or if we would just need a
move overload of Const ref
versus ref ref. It's unclear
what this L value form does cuz
correct me if I'm wrong, it's
value that cares about it's not
really error.
The value is fully overloaded on
L value versus R value and
modifiable versus Const, and the
function could absolutely care
about that because if I want to
modify if I'm like a function
that takes int ref and then goes
modifies the thing I really care
if the value is modifiable.
Umm.
This do we move the value?
We do.
Yeah.
OK, so that argues more strongly
that.
So.
Oh, go ahead.
Ohh yeah so so that that goes
back to your point of like
wanting to reject.
Temporary is like if somebody
has a function that takes an.
That takes in. Don't know
sometime and then return the
reference to that type in, like
a new type. You really want that
to not be a temporary.
And so you could reject our
values by doing that.
If that makes sense.
So basically something like
this.
Where you want to take a thing.
You know, maybe do stuff and
then return a reference to the
thing, but if you're giving any
Cerner temporary, you just need
to reject that on site, which is
sort of similar scenario. We
Yeah.
haven't, like, refrigerator and
whatever, where you have a valid
reason for observing sometimes,
but because we maintain a
persistent reference elsewhere,
we need to reject temporary. So
this really cares about constar
value references. So that's a
good motivation to have all
four. OK, so I think.
I think that that's an argument
for. I guess we're kind of
resolving the issue or think
about the issue itself here to
have all four overloads. But in
that case, then that does argue
to correctly constrain all of
them.
Umm.
Although the sorry, the
constraint only cares about E,
the argument for what we do with
E is less important than what we
send to the function. Cause like
if you have an arbitrary
function, the scenario of ohh
you know doesn't want to reject
our values, that's interesting.
If it's purely the question of
can we copy or move EE should
really not care if it's being
constructed from.
Modifiable value versus constel
value.
More constar value.
So I think.
Having the two specifications
here that says deck type value
and decltype stood move value,
that's definitely still
necessary. I think the only
question is for the error case,
how do we constrain and what do
we return?
I I could see Argo. OK, so I
guess this is less simple and
less obvious than originally
thought.
Umm, which now moves me towards.
Let's file an issue and come
back to this later in the
implementation because it will
really only make a difference if
somebody calls the constar value
version of this and if the E
type cares about it and that's
so obscure like in practice like
we wouldn't even have found this
Umm yeah.
in that implementation in the
test of the implementation
itself. It's only when we
exhaustively reviewed it, OK.
Yeah.
Frankly, I don't even think this
needs to be a constraint at all
Umm.
like.
It is very weird to sphene based
on whether the expected like
phone away and then based on
whether unexpected.
Is copy constructible like what
the what are you doing that you
Yeah, because like you.
need that sphinx constraint?
What?
Because you can't Sweeney away
based on the call ability of the
the function you pass in anyway
so.
It's like you. You can't, like
parsh, partially spinach the way
Yeah, like why, what are you
doing?
That's a good point.
you're you're overloads that.
So that would, that would argue
just for cause like I think the
standard is actually gotten
maybe a little bit overboard on
service thing, things in the
constraints that really should
only be when we really want the
function to participate in like
overload resolution nicely.
Otherwise it should either be a
mandate or should just be in the
standard. It should be a mandate
in the implementation. It should
be we're going to do a thing and
then if it fails to compile well
you get the compile error and
have fun.
Yeah.
And this really feels like that,
because I mean if the.
Or like static cast or static a
certain, not static cast.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, yeah.
Implemented through a mandate.
Yeah. It's so that that's an
argument for dropping the
constraint entirely.
That would be my preferred
resolution.
Yeah, that, that.
Yeah.
OK. We talked about this in the
video code review and while this
is definitely an issue, it is
surprisingly subtle. So we
should file an issue, file an
LWG issue, and wait for it to be
resolved. It could be reasonable
to drop the constraints on these
overloads entirely. What
overload resolution scenario
would they be improving?
Sounds good to me.
OK, finding bugs in the
standard.
OK. So we are in the constructor
of overload, which is the one
causing us all this trouble.
Constexpr auto and then for the
refund consider frac. He's in
Utah, his move C Rev invoke
result T.
How we've got we've got a little
the different here, OK, because
that's the the decal type of
stood move.
Of value. OK, let me make sure
that this is all correct.
I think I I think I glossed over
this the first time I saw this.
So the L value form needs to say
Tyra F.
Constant values is const. Tyra
off.
Our value says tie.
Tom Star values is constant, all
correct.
OK. And then stack of Serge is
specialization, return Type F
must be specialization of
expected for the R value ones.
Seven. Is the mandate correct?
And then type name Utah error
type must be error.
Yes, airtime must be easy. If
his value stood, invoke stood
Ford Fund funks did move value
that's right. Otherwise you tie
unexpected move unexpected. OK.
That's and then now or else.
Ah OK. Template on class fun
requires is copy constructible V
of tie. So that's this
constraint.
Constexpr auto or else
photographer funk? I guess we're
going to see we're going to see
the same sort of issue here.
Or actually know only for the
error.
There's asking about tea, not
east.
We move value. Oh, but the same
issue that the constant the
constant refresh one.
OK, so this occurs in all of
them.
Yeah, I'm on the on, not in
transfer transform and transform
Because it's asking me for
structure, OK.
error don't have constraints on
them but and then and or else
OK.
do.
We should fix this or else.
So using a phone or funk I'll
wrap. OK is in Utah remove CV
raft, invoke result T fun on.
Decker type of error.
Which is Arraf. I'll quickly
scan Const araf.
Error as an R value const error.
OK great.
Uh, OK, stack assert Utah must
be expected.
Where's your tie? Oh, you tie
the return value. Yep. I'm
double checking. The name is
correctly changed. Or else here.
Return type F must be
specialization of expected 11.
Is the mandate cracked also for?
That Const L value. This one
also says or else here I'm just
quickly scanning. I'm still are
else 15 for the R value. Yep.
Tyler's 15 OK, so all the
messages are good.
Let's go back up.
Go.
OK, let me to value type, OK. If
it's value then return Utah of
the in place tag and value. This
is the lvalue form otherwise
stood invoke stood forward from
funk unexpected. OK great.
Then there's the construct one.
We've already checked that we've
checked the messages in place
value student Vokes deferred
from funk. Unexpected. OK,
great.
Our value.
We checked the type being fed to
invoke result there and the
messages. I guess I did not
actually check the spaces, but
the spaces all look good for the
line wrapping OK.
Umm, so this one. Now it needs
moves.
Here we go. So move the value,
move the error stood move value
stood move unexpected. You still
got stood qualification
everywhere. Good. And then the
construct ref.
STD move values did move
unexpected. OK, that's all the
OR else is.
Uh, getting faster at this. Now
transform template class fun.
Requires this copy constructible
V the error.
That's this one.
Constexpr auto transform.
And refer funk. Actually
transform also has the.
I was wrong. Yeah, they do have
the. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, this has the same problem,
yeah.
And the transform error. OK, so
it's actually all of them. I'll
go back up.
Morales transformer.
Transformer. OK, let's go back
down.
Transform.
OK.
It's got structure. The error
constexpr auto transform fund
refer funk L ref.
Uh. We begin with the static
assert static assert.
The invocable concept? Uh,
because that's the mandate.
Yeah, so, so basically the the
issue with this mandate is that.
Well, that's interesting.
So it mandates that that
declaration is valid in order to
work out the type you you need
to do invoke result T of fun and
tie. So I have to I do a kind of
multi stage approach where
because in order to work out the
the you you need to do the
Yeah.
invoke results. So first I check
that it's invokable and it's
just static cert if not and then
because I know that invoking is
safe.
And I do it and then I check the
rest of the.
That the mandates clause.
Yeah, that's very interesting,
because if you didn't do this,
then attempting to form the
invoke result that would seen
away and so we'd get an error
like, hey, you're trying to make
a UTI type def, but it didn't
have such a nested double colon
type. That would be technically
conformant, but pretty horrible
message. So I really like this.
This will result in better user
experience if the function is
not invokable with the value for
whatever reason, and that could
easily happen. If anything, it's
more likely than like, oh, The
Yeah.
thing is in copy constructible,
it's just like you're trying to
Right. Yeah, absolutely.
call some Lambda and you've got
the type wrong or too many types
or something, or too few.
OK, so let's double check this
multi stage deal. So we're
static asserting that fun is
invocable Thai ref because that
matches what we're going with
the invoke result.
We got to say expected TE form
F.
Uh requires that F is invocable
with T. Again, glossing over the
value category, which is
reasonable.
Umm, looks like we do have a
space there. Yep.
Umm site expected object monadic
paragraph 19.
Yep, that's the mandate. OK, so
now we know that's an invocable,
and now we can actually form
Utah. Using Utah is remove CVT.
We're not removing CV ref here.
Umm invoke result T of fun on
Tyreke? That's the deck of type
of value. So now we have U.
And then.
Uh mandates you is a valid value
type for expected, which is
happening down here outside the
if constexpr.
OK, check expected argument. You
type value and This is why this
is factored out.
This is not being asserted with
a message, but that's because
check expected argument emits
nice messages messages is. I
can't pluralize for all of the
different failure scenarios. It
Yeah.
would be confusing and redundant
to also cite. Hey, you know,
it's really this mandates here
it should be fairly clear like
we're complaining about an
expected the template
instantiation context will show
that there's a transform. It
should be pretty
self-explanatory.
It's also always true.
Yeah. Ohh, you're right. Yeah.
This one is always true. Yeah.
Value is always true for this
case.
So we can't pass the message
even if we wanted to.
Umm OK.
Yeah, you would have to like
completely duplicate all of the
Hence the this is cute. I like
it.
static asserts inside the. It
would be a a mess for not a lot
of of benefit really.
Yeah.
OK, so that's nice. So now we've
checked this, then if is void V
of U as false. So if we're not
void V then we're gonna static
assert some stuff this thing.
Using the special is invoke
constructible.
Uh fun tie ref. Expected TEF
requires that the return type of
F.
Is constructible with the result
of invoking app.
OK.
And then site and 4928 expect
object 19 and this is.
This is wrapped a little bit
weirdly, and these could be
stacked onto a single line, uh.
I guess it's more consistent.
I think Clang format did that.
Oh, interesting. I think you
could probably manually set it
the other way.
But uh.
Yeah, if you if you had
originally written this on one
line and then this on the next
cling form, it would wrap this
I wrote it on one line and then
did a yeah.
one.
Ah, OK.
Is that consistent with what we
do elsewhere? This always
appears it's a little bit weird.
I won't. I won't comment on it
is consuming a bunch of lines.
It's not. It's not too weird.
It doesn't make it longer.
OK, I'm I can't resist. I'm
going to comment.
These can be.
Yeah. Can six join those last
two lines? Yeah.
On uh, these can be combined.
Yeah, if this code wasn't
already pretty long, I'd be
like, yeah, OK. We can spend a
line here, but it occurs like
four or more times and it's so
cheap to fix.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah, OK.
I'll say I lost my place and I
removed this. We're just
transform transform. OK, so
we're citing this 19 is the
mandates. OK, so we've got all
this here. Now, we've checked
the expected argument now we
implement.
OK. So affects, we've got three
conditions.
If has value, but the standard
specifies the false case. So we
do that first, and this is good.
Thank you for phrasing all of
these conditions positively. We
have a convention where we try
to avoid unnecessary negation in
conditions.
It's sometimes it makes stuff
clearer.
Yeah, it just makes the codes a
lot easier to read, I think.
Yeah. Otherwise gets tangled up.
You're like, wait, is this the
negative case and what's going
on here? So if it's value, do
Yeah.
positive stuff. Otherwise we
don't value.
Than return make an expected and
reforming utai error. Here we
should use braces of unexpect
and then the error which is
unexpected.
OK, let's see. This is a
different enough in the text
that I'll. I'll make a separate
comment for this.
Umm.
We can use braces when
constructing.
Uh curves below.
Yeah. Then actually. Oh, it
occurs everywhere here. Ding,
Ding, Ding, all these all these
cases. Let me.
Yeah. So and every case in where
we are explicitly constructing
Yeah.
an expected then should just
braces.
Mostly.
These temporary they're all
expected Utah error.
Can you use braces and
instructing these?
Her her peated land law. OK, we
can use braces when constructing
these expected. You tie air
objects occurs repeatedly below.
OK.
Yeah.
Umm.
The the ones where there's like
arguments is a little bit lower
priority and we certainly have a
lot of.
I'm.
Older usages, but when new code
is nice.
OK, so if has value false then
expected UE unexpected error. OK
got that.
Otherwise.
Umm if is void, V is false. Wow,
the standard flips all of these.
Umm.
That's this case.
Returns an expected UE object.
Who's?
Hazel Member is true.
So construct is expected from
invoke result tag.
And then the Val member is
direct non list initialize so
it's saying do not use braces
with invoke stirred Ford F value
OK.
Otherwise, this one evaluates
invoke stood Ford F.
And value and then returns
expected UE.
Print, print, brace, brace. OK,
so all looks good here. You ties
void. So there's no need to
ignore anything.
And this was already
implemented? Or is this
implemented below?
That constructor is implemented.
And.
Below.
OK, so here's naive benzene.
The the tag is is above and the
the constructor is below.
Right.
OK whoops, that's my place.
OK transform L ref.
Great. OK. So the new
constructor.
OK, so now the construct
version. Let me check the
paragraphs real quick. So.
El Raff mandates is 19 for Const
Graff or Rifraff, it's 23, it's
1923.
Yeah, OK, maximize this because
the wrapping is horrible. OK,
so.
This is the era off version
sighting 1919.
Constructif, which is the next
one, 1919.
And then Ruff Ruff 23232323. OK
good.
So consider if.
Template copy constructible
here. I'm not looking at the
standard, I'm just looking for
the differences that I'm
expecting, so we should see
consti ref for each of these.
But the messages don't need to
change.
OK, we still got the remove CVT.
So where does the construct
appear invokable when we make
the invoke result and then when
we ask our, you invoke
constructable?
No changes down here because we
just say value, but then the
move one will be a little bit
different. Here we say for the
reference one tie, tie, tie.
And then we stood move value
stood move. Value stood, move
unexpected. And then for Contra
frac, we say constant constant
constant I.
Stood move values should move
values to move unexpected OK
that looks good. I don't see any
copy paste errors here.
Quickly scanning for anything
else.
Don't see any issues.
Cap that looks good and then.
The Ruff Ruff won.
Yeah, that looks good.
Then account Straff 10 it
requires a different. We already
talked about this where it's
copy, copy, move, move, but that
should probably change. Yep,
copy.
Copy, move, move. OK.
And the construct raffone.
The Invocable not invoke
constructible.
OK.
Talks good. Now transform error.
So let's actually look at the
standard again.
Left.
OK, Tryon.
Transform error.
Our first.
Down here. OK template class F
constexpr auto transform error.
FL ref version.
OK, same multistep deal we
static assert.
Speaker OK, transform error
stack assert invokable fun.
Well, this is a little bit
different with error ref.
Because Gene needs to be
removed, CVS invoke result of
the decal type of error.
OK, air ref.
We we had high ref and Const
hired for the L value ones up
here, right? Yes. OK, good. We
weren't dropping her off.
OK so here stack assert,
invocable fun with Arref
expected TE form error. F
requires that F is invocable
with E OK, that's correct, no
copy paste errors for 27.
Yep, that's the right mandate.
K and then use new tie as remove
CVT, invoke result T fun air ref
stack cert is invoke
constructable. Fun error. Raff
expected TE transform error if
requires that the return type of
F is constructible with the
result of invoking F OK, that
doesn't need to mention error
again site 27.
Umm, so that's all the mandates.
Sarah bugging the standard here
it says Gee is valid value type
for expected, but then the
static assert is checked
unexpected argument for Utah.
Yes, that was a a bug in the
standard. I think Casey if you.
Click on the the conversation,
yeah.
This one.
Ah, excellent.
Yeah, I figured out. I figured
out an issue without cracking
the common open first.
Your cat.
I am paying attention.
OK, great. And we've already got
an issue that's in voting
status. Thank you.
OK.
It's it's so nice. The standard
two include these little little
gems to find.
OK, so we are doing the right
thing here. Even though the
standard says the wrong thing,
Utah's gotta be a valid,
unexpected argument, OK?
So we've already checked your
invocable. You formed Utah
invoke constructible. So that's.
All this.
Make G with invoke F on error.
OK, because G is the folk
resolve. OK, that looks good.
OK, so then the actual
implementation sets if we have a
value, if his value is true,
return expected TG which is Ty
Utah from in place and value
correct otherwise.
On expected TG object. So Thai
utai whose Hazel inverse false.
So constructive Spector from
vocal result tag unexpected.
Umm. And then he'd be direct non
list initialized with invoke
forward FF. So switchboard, funk
and error unexpected. OK great
and then the usual move changes
there OK.
So construct.
Um or I should check before I
minimize that the mandates
paragraph?
27 and 31 OK.
So for the L version 2727.
And spaces here try 727 and then
31313131. Perfect.
OK, construct O. We expect to
see concern Arav, concert rap
Concert, RAF.
But we still say value and
unexpected.
OK, that's good.
And then the rough rough
version, which now says move
constructible here. Let's good
here we have error, error,
error, move value move
unexpected Alstead qualified
good.
And then concert or counselor,
Prof is cancer. Cancer, cancer.
Stood move. Value should move
unexpected.
Great.
And then the quality operators
fix up these strengthens OK
implementation of the
constructor. Let's see are we
getting close to the end of
expected. I know we're getting
close to the end of our time
slot then we've got the void
specialization, OK, which is
gonna be of course pretty highly
repetitive. I think we might
wanna call it a wrap once we get
to the end of the primary
template and I'll review the
rest offline.
But like that was pretty much
exactly my my reaction when I
Umm.
was doing the standard and all
this stuff, and I was like, oh,
no, I've got the void ones.
Uh, it's like ohh, it's a whole
extra sequel. OK, so I lost my
Yeah.
place. Uh, the constructor, OK.
So nice comment explaining why
we're doing this thing. These
overloads force copy elision
from the invoke call into value.
OK.
Ah, so we have several overloads
here.
One takes a function and Arg.
One takes a funk by itself or in
Transformers called on an
expected void E.
Ah.
How do we do the specializations
of expect? Isn't it an entirely
different specialization?
So so yes, it's an entirely
different specialization, but
it's when you're calling
transform on an expected void E
Ah.
such that it then needs to
construct our expected TE.
But you need to call that
invokable with no arguments, so
the the TE primary template
needs.
OK.
And that constructor, which
takes no argument to pass to the
invocable.
Makes sense?
OK, let's see. OK, see.
Basically, exactly this is the
same thing.
OK, Casey was confused about the
Maybe that means I need to
change the comment?
Hilarious.
Yeah, nitpick space after coming
here.
OK. Umm OK, these. Yeah, we saw
that template class, fun class
UX. Constexpr constructor.
Expected.
And we take the tag here. The
tag occurs first, which is most
helpful for tag dispatch. Here
is a necessary case for tag
dispatch. Basically or tag. I
guess that's not really
dispatch, it's more like
disambiguation.
I'm because constructors don't
have names. Fun rough of funk UX
ref ref Arg.
We are no except, but this is
all internal, so no reason to
come in is strengthened.
We're not. We're not. Except if
this is noexcept.
Let's make a tie. This probably
be a static cast. It invokes did
Fortran function before. Do you
XRG?
Yeah, I think I think let's,
let's phrase this as a static
cast as well.
Yeah.
Smile for using.
Static cast here.
And in the below 2 reloads as
well.
Now OK.
Yeah.
And then construct value with
student Vogue stood forward from
funk stood 40X. RG has value
such a true as an aside boy it
would be nice if the standard
Committee was able to add
features that avoided the
repetitiveness of this code.
It's like that's just go and
look through what library
implementers are suffering
through and help them write more
elegant code which will help
everyone.
OK, rant over 4.
That's one for no except auto.
The.
Yeah.
There are reasons to be
uncomfortable with it, but the
alternative is so bad, and I was
so happy when we got like
expected or sorry explicit bool.
So convenient.
Yeah.
OK, so this is the helper tag.
From there funk I wonder.
We could make this variadic, but
making it variadic just to
handle the zero or one case.
Is not the biggest thing in the
world.
Umm, I guess that oh, and this
allows you to bypass the invoke,
There's also the case where.
Yes. So the this, the standard
does say to use invoke here, but
yeah.
I thought couldn't just call the
function.
Absolutely. Because if there's
no arguments, yeah, because if.
Avoid the invoke call. Yeah,
they can't be a Member Pointer
or a member function pointer,
so.
Yeah, it would need a class
object or pointer thing.
OK, so that's a nice.
Metaprogramming throughput
optimization. We're no except if
this is no, except the construct
the tie from directly calling
the funk.
Said has value true.
So many parentheses looks like
Lisp.
Yeah.
And then, funny wax, if we have
an unexpected tag, all the tags
function RG.
And these are these are
unambiguous because it's, um.
Whenever I see heavy overload. I
tried to make sure that there's
no possibility for ambiguity.
This is 3 args disambiguated on
the first tag, two and four, so
purely by errity, these can
never conflict with each other,
so that's good.
And in the most dire case of
tuple, we have these internal
tags that help us fully
disambiguate which one we need,
and we have a very careful
template. Any trick to avoid
ever impulsively constructing
those things that's not
necessary here, I think.
Yeah, I thought about like
making a construct expected from
Umm.
invoke tag unexpected or
something, but I thought I can
just we've already gotten
unexpected. I can just use that.
Yeah, that does seem reasonable.
Umm, no, except if noexcept
construct the error, this one
Static cast again get.
could also be static cast.
Also for error.
Avoid.
Uh, just a avoid a ton of
comments here.
Error. Student Vogue storefront
from Funks did 40X RG.
And then construct the
unexpected from that has value
set to false. OK, great. And
then we're up to the void
specialization. Wonderful.
OK. And we are exactly at the
end of our time slot. So I think
I will pause here. Let's see.
I'm thinking should I submit
this review and then come back
in cause a lot of the
recommended changes are in
effect the void one as well.
Umm.
I'm tempted to do that and then.
Well.
One thing is I've already made
all of the changes which you've
suggested, including in the Void
specialization.
Ah, nice. So fast. And then the
test, which I'll come back and
review.
Yeah, OK. I think I'll submit my
review now. I will look for your
changes and then I will resume
at the void specialization. I
will add a comment.
A here. This is purely a note to
self. Actually, no, I don't need
to add a comment, that's
annoying. I will add it in the
review itself.
Great.
Uh.
Thanks, um. Note to self. I
reviewed the product code up to
the Boyds specialization and
still need to review.
The new.
Test file OK.
Cool. I just pushed all of those
changes as well.
Excellent. I'll come back and
review the rest of it later
today.
And this is looking great and
thank you for implementing this
and we should hopefully be able
to move this forward to is this
an final review right now Casey
Casey did approve, OK. So it is
in final review.
So once I sign off.
And I the necessary changes are
like small, I might go ahead and
push them anyways if they don't
need your expertise then we
should be able to get this ready
to merge and hopefully merge.
Great.
This week we just missed the
deadline for getting changes
into 17-6 Preview 2, although
the date for that to actually
releases in the future. We don't
say exactly when, but the
internal branch deadline for
changes flowing is already
passed so this is now slated to
go into 17 seven.
But it will be one of the first
changes in 17-7.
And.
Let's see. That will bring us.
This is over 5% of our remaining
C + 23 features we're at. I
guess I can open up this project
here.
Here we go. Yeah. We have
rapidly diminishing set of C +
23 features to implement,
although the committee is voting
in more stuff this week.
Hopefully not actual features,
just like patch papers. So the
total number of papers might
increase, but hopefully no new
massive things will come in.
Umm, so thanks. UMI think that
does it for this video code for
you and we'll see you next week.
Great. Thanks so much.